what you can't do is tell the rest of
the world how to live you just said I
can have it in my community yes okay so
we can have it in my community but not
in someone else's case in terms of a
private community
Center there's no private Community what
is your church your church is a
community but my community is Nashville
Tennessee
can declare one correct view of the
truth for all its residents I mean but
it does you could live you could live in
that do those kinds of things all states
are like that because all states have
laws and they declare certain things
true and others Falls and some elicit
and some illicit and those stay crafted
that's typically done where the
intersection of Rights occurs where one
person's right to swing their fists ends
where another person's face begins not
when it comes to questions of individual
beliefs being policed like who gets to
go into a bathroom well who gets who
owns the bathroom they can make the rule
you don't own the bathroom but I don't
what about the military bathrooms and
the school bathrooms the military it can
have its policies about that's the
government so yeah